okay today I'm going to talk about
photosynthesis so photosynthesis is a
process which occurs in plants where
plants use energy from light to make
glucose so essentially the glucose acts
as the plant's food the plant can use
this glucose for energy and can use it
for lots of different cellular processes
so where does this occur now in the
leaves of plants and the leaves of
plants this is where photosynthesis
happens there's lots of specialized
cells that are called palisade cells now
these cells so I'm just going to draw
the basic structure of a plant from a
plant cell these cells contain lots and
lots of these green organelles called
chloroplasts so this is the site of
photosynthesis and the cells within
leaves in plant cells called
chloroplasts and they contain a special
pigment called chlorophyll this special
pigment here this is the one that
absorbs the light from the Sun usually
allowing allowing photosynthesis to
occur so we need to know the word and
symbol equation for photosynthesis so we
have carbon dioxide plus water goes to
glucose and oxygen so carbon dioxide
this just comes from the air so it
enters the leaf and it just come by
diffusion and it comes from the air the
water gets absorbed through plant roots
by osmosis and then goes up to the leaf
so these are the two things that we need
for photosynthesis to occur the things
that are produced of glucose which could
use for four loads of different cellular
processes because it provides the energy
in aerobic respiration or anaerobic
respiration
and oxygen now this is a good news for
us because oxygen gets released from
plants and we actually need this to
breathe in for aerobic respiration as
well so um the other thing is sometimes
you might see the equation with light
and/or chlorophyll written above or
below the line notice how they're not
actually written as products or reaction
of reactants they're written above or
below the arrow this shows we need these
things in order for the reaction to
occur but they're not products and
reactants within themselves because
photosynthesis will only work if there's
light and it only works if there's
chlorophyll so let's see the symbol
equation right here so it's co2 plus h2o
hopefully we should know these symbols
here now blue codes the only one we
might not be comfortable with its c6
h-12 o-6 and oxygen is o2 and we should
know those so glucose the only one we're
really gonna have to make sure we can
remember now balancing it is dead simple
we just need a six here six here and a
six here six six six it's a nice way of
remembering it now the nice thing about
the equation for photosynthesis is it's
the same as the equation for R a support
aerobic respiration but only the
products which round with the reactants
so if you could remember the equation
for photosynthesis you should hopefully
also remember the equation for aerobic
respiration guess the last thing we need
to know at this stage just about the
basics of photosynthesis is the fact
that it's an endothermic reaction so all
that that means is energy is taken in
during this reaction so this is an
example of an endothermic reaction so
just to summarize photosynthesis is how
plants make glucose which is essentially
their food photosynthesis occurs in
leaves within palisade cells and
particularly within the chloroplasts
that's the organelle that contains
chlorophyll the reactants carbon dioxide
and water and the product of glucose and
oxygen this is an endo
process thanks for listening